[Music]
welcome back the shine a light
foundation will host its first annual a
night beneath the neon Gala in order to
raise money to assist the homeless
community and here to tell us about the
upcoming event we have Paul vote to know
thank you so much Paul for being here
thank you for having us so tell us a
little bit about the foundation uh shine
a light Foundation is a non-profit
organization that goes into the
underground flood channels to work with
the homeless that are you know basically
living beneath the Neon
its primary purpose really is a to just
establish relationships with them let
them know that you know somebody's
thinking about them somebody cares on
the back end though we are a very
complex case management program that
will help place them immediately if they
ever want to get out and case manage
them through the next 18 months helping
with job development resume development
clothes
treatment you know anything that they
could possibly need we kind of try to
wrap around it and fit the program to
their needs not you know a certain box
of what we can do we tailor it to them
well it's really important work that
you're doing right here in our community
and I know that the foundation is
important to you tell us a little bit
about why you created it well yeah so we
started the foundation five years ago
Matt O'Brien started shine a light about
10 years ago and I got interested in
the work really because I lived
underground I lived underground for
three years and uh you know the whole
time I was there nobody came by to see
us nobody you know I kind of got stuck
and lost in this you know illusion that
you know I was alone and
it just was really important to me as I
kind of got sober and got cleaned up
that I figured out a way to kind of give
back to that space and hopefully change
the narrative around that well I love
that it just shows how support can
change a life and go such a long way and
this Gala it's the first one happening
at the space December 10th tell us about
it yeah we're gonna have uh Darren
Waller from the Raiders he's going to
perform some music for us uh Johann Hari
is uh world-renowned writer he's going
to come out he'll be our keynote speaker
and really hopefully we can just raise
some money to help launch us into next
year you know last year we pulled 81
people out of homelessness and this year
alone we're at like 285 so the goal is
just to keep up with the need and
continue to grow and support and how
does it feel to have the community
behind you in supporting the
organization yeah it's it's humbling
right like I think 10 years ago like
sitting here in this space like it just
wouldn't seem sellable to to me you know
and it's kind of an honor to be trusted
in this situation and to to be given the
opportunity to kind of help somebody
else find what I found well Paul thank
you so much for sharing all of this with
us and we're so glad that this
organization was able to help you and
now you're here with us today that is
really special and you're a Las Vegas
local too grew up here I'll be a
graduate so we ought to stick together
well all the information is on your
screen a night beneath the neon gala
happening December 10th at the space you
can get the tickets at the website on
the screen Paul thank you so much yeah
thank you for having us JC over to you
that's a